chuckles like bad guys like you I mess
it up every time maybe you just need a
partner
dr. PIM I actually heard what happened
to you it's crazy could be goes solar
tech
so you sold about use on kill and
chassis crap
is both the deal and man in the wasp
teaming up follow my lead
[Music]
awesome even you won't on you
hi hf how was school today so cranky
hey everybody its charlie
today is like new trailer day we got new
a man in the wasp footage we got details
on a new spider-man trailer coming later
this week that I'll explain in a whole
bunch of spider-verse stuff so if you're
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos there's
a new round of that infinity war DVD
giveaway going on all you have to do to
enter that is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on the video I'll name a new
winner at the end of this we should
really call this the babylegs
ant-man trailer you make all the
Deadpool all the rick and morty jokes
that you want it just seems like there
are a lot of people making hundred and
fifty million dollar movies that are dan
harmon justin roiland fans this year you
sure found this guy quick if you're not
a big Rick and Morty ban that's from
Rick's T minutes it's season 1 episode 8
but obviously the whole joke is just
predicated on the idea that his
shrinking technology malfunctions while
he's shrinking down so he just gets
stucked like that for a little while so
he has to run around like he's a little
kid there's a little bit of them
fighting the ghost together like you see
the alley oop we've seen a little bit of
that in previous trailers but you get a
little more Walton Goggins in like
really like just moving into
spider-verse territory because I know
everybody's wondering about that Phil
Lord and Chris Miller said there'd be a
new trailer coming on Wednesday like
they just said webs day so obviously
they're talking about spider-man stuff
that's gonna be for the spider-verse
movie with Miles Morales that'll be
dropping later this year the animated
movie that's the one that they've been
working on wait so how many
inside the spider-verse and with
spider-man homecoming - we got a bunch
more details from a bunch of different
things so just going down the roster
spider-man - we'll start filming in July
per Kevin Feige but they're filming in
London so obviously it's gonna be much
more international than the last movie
they didn't say that they would not be
going back to New York City like
obviously they'll have to go back at
some point because I'll have to meet up
with Aunt May but he also said that it
wouldn't be called spider-man - he said
that there would be a subtitle they just
haven't revealed it yet they might
reveal what that is at Comic Con this
year even though they're not doing a big
Hall H panel but that's really on Sony
Sony's gonna be the people marketing the
spider-man movie we've made all kinds of
jokes about how they're gonna market it
while spider-man is supposed to be dead
even though we know he's coming back we
got some really cool concept art for
carnage in the venom movie even though
he hasn't been confirmed to appear yet
now obviously this is based on the
liquid look of the symbiote that Tom
Hardy is wearing
[Music]
why would we do if you're gonna stay you
will only hurt bad people do I see it
can do whatever we want do we have a
deal
[Applause]
you willing to sacrifice
one thing you hold most dear
you should be extremely afraid
what the hell are you
[Music]
so per the trailers what they might end
up doing is instead of having the
carnage symbiote be the child of the
Venom symbiote it'll just be one of
these other symbiotes that they find
like you have a couple canisters here so
there's more than one symbiote in the
venom one is just the one that bonds
with Eddie Brock but I think what's
gonna happen at Comic Con this summer is
that Sony will mostly be pushing new
venom stuff so we'll probably get
another trailer for that then we might
get to see Woody Harrelson's character
because right now he is the leading
rumor for the carnage character but
supposedly he's not showing up til the
end of the film and it'll be like a big
sequel thing like the way that movie is
sort of surfaced the villain at the end
they did the exact same thing with
spider-man homecoming and setting up the
sinister six at the end of that
look who it is what are the odds you and
I'd end up at the same summer camp relax
this it's not on you it's on our little
spider friend I've got some boys on the
outside who would love to meet him you
know take a picture slice his throat but
his head in the dryer and I heard a
rumor No so I'm actually kind of
wondering if that's what spider-man
to subtitle will be like rise of the
sinister six or something like that
it'll probably be a little bit simpler
than that
but you may have also heard about them
taking silver and black off of the
schedule if you didn't know they're
making a black cat silver sable team-up
movie but apparently they weren't happy
with the script so they're going back to
baseline whatever that ends up being
it'll be completely different so I think
that's a good thing
I would rather Sony just spend the time
they need to make good spider-verse
movies rather than just try and crank
them out I think like a thief a boat
full of overdressed fat cats is a
can't-miss proposition wait now waters
is wearing the Stuyvesant Tiger I am
genuinely excited to see black cats show
up in the spider-man movies but I think
the real question is is how are these
movies going to invoke the spider-man
mythos because I think you could do
silver and black without spider-man but
you can't really do venom without any
kind of spider-man especially if he's
gonna have the spider symbol on this
chest I think he does have it they just
have an interesting way of invoking it
like it's not exactly like it is in the
comics so I am expecting the classic
venom look for that symbiote if you guys
haven't been reading the comics they
actually just gave him the symbiote back
but there's this big fan of style finger
snap with the red goblin who's the
Norman Osborn Green Goblin fused with
the carnage symbiote so if you're big
spider-man comic book fan now is
probably a good time to jump back on the
comics because they're do some really
cool stuff there's a whole bunch more
trailers that drop today so I'll try to
get to that as fast as possible
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner Mighty Mite 27 please private
message me so I can get your contact
details click here to learn all about
Captain
Marvel and click here for brand-new
Avengers for thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]
you